bill plasticky joining us on the program
bill good morning thanks for joining us
as LeBron lived up to what I guess you
know Laker fans thought he was going to
be yes he has he has now Dan he's become
and I and I wrote this in LA times I
think he became a Laker the first game
after Kobe's passing when he spoke to
the fans and connected with him and then
record everything that's happened before
then and since then he's really invested
in this team he's really engaged and
he's really great again oh my god people
here realized how good he is and he's
and last night was very cool because you
know on the same court where they were
mourning Kobe Chloe just 24 hours
earlier in fact it was so it was the
morning that was so encompassed him so
much I don't believe he came to the
ceremony he didn't even come to the
ceremony and he couldn't he couldn't
handle it and yet he comes out the next
night
he's a oldest player to score at least
40 at Staples Center since Kobe dropped
60 back in his retirement game that was
kind of cool but yes he is really he's
in and you know all these MVP chants are
really for real I mean I don't see how
this guy this guy's got a PEP
well I've been saying that to Bill I
thought I said we forgot about LeBron
that he had one immortally MVP since
2012 2013 and he's we've taken him for
granted and it almost feels like there's
an anti LeBron bias elsewhere around the
league that you're looking for somebody
hey lets you know Harden and Westbrook
and the Greek freak while they're all
wonderful players this year you know I
said what better storyline for people
because we do love our stories and
LeBron would be I think I think he
should be the frontrunner for the MVP oh
yeah no I mean he cares the team up
until Kobe's passing and then think oh
he's done since then I mean all the
turmoil and this team could been torn
apart in the towns torn apart and
everybody torn apart and he shows up
every night and just falls out every
night and is he's unbelievable at his
age and the way he's playing in a way
he's leading this day and he's a clear
leader of it of the team and he's
brought them together and he you know he
an ad or playing tremendously together
and they don't have much around them and
there
you're beating the hell that everybody
yeah I mean they haven't go to a fourth
quarter lead this season I mean he's
he's humble he's been unbelievable and
again given this you talk about the
storyline given circumstances and all
this and you have to understand this can
not only did they go through since
Kobe's passing did they hit you know
they have the the first game against
Portland back there and it was you know
it was like a public wake and it was so
awful and melodramatic and really
difficult to get through they go through
this every in every road place they play
for the first time Kobe's honored so it
gets brought back up every place they go
they're surrounded by that you know the
city is trying to move on with the
grieving and everyone's trying to move
on finally I think they came at they
can't move on their surrounding light
every night every night and LeBron shows
up every night and also he talks
I think it's underrated the fact that in
today's media you know everybody talks
about players being not accessible
he talks every day and he says something
intelligent every day to the media and
he he represents the team he represents
the city yeah he's he is so far from
what happened last year he has really
become he's become a Laker he's become
an Angeleno people here just absolutely
love him if I gave the Lakers a mulligan
and said you could you could trade away
Kuzma instead of Ingram what they have
done that kept when they still made that
deal no they wouldn't have made that
deal I know they they a but what I think
they knew I think there was there's a
reason New Orleans wanted and demanded
Ingram and there's a reason Orleans
settled for not taking Koosman I think
we're seeing that reason now
Kyle's a nice little player but I think
he's he got a little bit of Hollywood
and I think he got a little bit lost his
way a little bit and he's not really the
factor they need and this is huge
because I think is great is LeBron you
were doing in Milan is gonna be the MVP
can he keep up in the playoffs without a
third piece I don't know you know and
all the minutes he's played I mean look
at the minutes he's played in 30 minutes
he on his place Yonex plays like eight
or nine less minutes a game means as he
stored stuff up for the playoffs yes I
think and that's and that's that's still
the big issue here is that everyone says
can these two guys hold up
the postseason Kenny hold up against the
Clippers in a tough you know seven-game
series they can't hold up without the
fact getting the Darren Collison the
third piece they really wanted without
getting a shooter heck you're talking
the dion Waiters now did you hear that I
know I know I know and junior Smith and
I went on no no I know so that that is
the that see the the other shoe dropping
here is what happens then and I think
the town is kind of so everybody's
thrilled abroad and you know and you
know really admires how he's you know
overcome all this stuff and they're
really dealing with their input
everybody's really worried that what's
going to happen in in May against in
Staples Center against the Clippers or
against the Nuggets or against the but I
don't think they're as good as a bucks
at all I know and I don't think anybody
anybody thinks that so Ken they exceeded
at that last piece and then robbed of
course the men have to make the deal Rob
pálinka well glossed his best friend so
you know there's so much they're going
through out here and there's so much to
tomorrow about how they've handled every
day we're talking to Bill Pulaski LA
Times columnist and contributor to
ESPN's around the horn
I was wondering with Xion Williamson
that the hype for him it felt like it
was more than LeBron even though LeBron
was a high schooler on the cover of
Sports Illustrated but Zion had this he
had that one year where he's on national
TV for 31 games with Duke and living up
to those expectations can you can you
remember back with LeBron can you
compare these two are they on the same
level as far as that hype that
surrounded them coming in ya know I
think LeBron I was as one who was old
enough to remember I covered LeBron's
high school game at Pauley Pavilion and
I ripped into the how could a high
school team travel across the country
and play and miss these regional mentor
business classes and I was a shout back
then I don't think we can compare again
I just don't I don't think tsiyon had
did I don't know K how many people
watched him I mean in high school you
know they watched his dunks and
everything but LeBron was on national TV
since he was you know 15 or 14 years old
or something I mean I I still think
LeBron does the models the standard for
the toughness
of having to grow up under the social
media age I really do but I tell you
what size really he's really good my
goodness and so he's so fast
he's so fast he's so big and but but you
saw what happened last night in the
fourth quarter you know LeBron took over
the nose ion you know it's still you
know it's still it's killed it it's just
a kid learning his way one other thing
Tom Verducci made a great baseball
reporter broadcaster he was talking
about this courtesy of Major League
Baseball Network he had the following to
say about the World Series with Clayton
Kershaw facing the Astros in 2017 it's
interesting when I went back and look at
this game again you're looking at it in
hindsight with more knowledge we have
now than we had then Kershaw through 51
sliders and curveballs that day and got
zero swings and misses on them yeah that
alone will make you start thinking that
something was up
what do you make of that oh it's what
I've been writing about for three months
here a screwdriver championship oh there
was no question there's no I you know
and I'm not saying the Commissioner ever
should have given the Dodgers the title
because they didn't think I didn't win
on the field but it should really say
Cady they were they were jobs out of
that championship I was there for every
pitch they were they win Game five they
win that they win the World Series
there's no question they had at least as
good of a team as the Astros that year
Kershaw blowing - first of all granted
he we all know he blows leaves and
postseason but he hadn't blow 2 3 or 4
run leads the same game he didn't he
blew 2 twice now there's no question the
Dodgers were the ones that were really
robbed in this thing there was nobody
and his legacy think about his legacy
and you can't go back on that now and
even though people can say well you know
ok you know all the cheating scandal
hurt him he's still known as an October
failure yeah and this and this would H
is could have changed he gets out of
that game five everything for him
changes I don't care what he does
against the Nationals last year ok well
he had a bad game if it at least he's
got a championship ring it would have
changed everything
this affected lay that's why I've
actually players are so mad it's
affected Lake his death in spectre-1
season it affected lies infected
legacies his legacies forever affected
by
people just say he's never going to be
considered like sandy koufax out here
never even though he's better in Colfax
in every conceivable stat because of
that World Series because of those
playoffs because of what happened in
Game five against the Astros it's right
just wrong they're just wrong and that's
a Rob Manfred a piece of metal give me a
break I got your piece of metal pal yeah
oh my god you wrote a wonderful column
and you focused on Vanessa Bryant as you
said you know honest words and emotions
it really connected with people and you
know I wanted to have you on just to say
that you know you captured his spirit
there I know you were sitting there in
the audience and I don't know how you
could be taking notes with what was
going on because I'm watching I'm just
crying so I can't imagine being alone oh
I wasn't I wasn't taking notes we had a
tape recorder running and I was stunned
and you know it's actually kind of words
I appreciate it I was stunned she she
spoke I thought she I know Michael
Jordan cried and it was really a
compelling but the fact that Vanessa
spoke she is she said more Dan she said
more in that service then she has said
him for 20 years previously publicly she
never she's private she never and to
talk about your your daughter daughter
and your husband like that oh my god the
strength she showed now I really hope
she takes up his mantle and becomes more
of a public figure and becomes you know
takes up his causes I hope that happens
out here hope she becomes a leading
figure and if you mean either way he was
because she's she's certainly ready for
that bill thanks for joining us we
appreciate it as always thanks that's
bill pleshkin LA Times and of course
around the horn contributor for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]